calculemos la curvatura de una curva
tridimensional y la que tengo en mente
se le conoce como hélice y las primeras
dos componentes de la función que
describe a la hélice la hacen parecer un
círculo entonces primero tendremos
coseno de t luego tendremos seno de t y
finalmente vamos a poner t
sobre 5 y la forma en la que se ve
podríamos visualizarla muy bien aquí
tenemos la gráfica y esta figura se le
conoce como hélice y puedes ver cómo
desde el plano xy desde esa perspectiva
todo parece como si estuviéramos
dibujando un círculo aquí por supuesto
las líneas deberían estar bien alineadas
pero como estamos trabajando con un poco
de perspectiva bueno algo se ve como un
espiral verdad pero en realidad debería
dibujarse un círculo ahora bien la
componente zeta debido a que se está
incrementando a medida que el parámetro
t también va incrementándose entonces
estamos como elevando nos es como como
una escalera en espiral de verdad o de
caracol
ahora antes de calcular la curvatura
queremos saber en realidad qué es lo que
esto representa digamos podríamos
imaginarnos no sé que estamos en un
camino o quizás en el espacio digamos
que estamos en una nave espacial verdad
podríamos imaginar que toda nuestra
maquinaria en algún punto se atasca
verdad no podríamos usar ningún control
digamos ni el volante o lo que sea que
que maneje esta nave espacial verdad y
entonces vamos a tener una trayectoria
en círculo verdad y ese círculo podría
parecerse más o menos a algo así
así que si estuviéramos girando digamos
en esta hélice de verdad pero de repente
no podemos hacer nada simplemente
trazaremos un gran círculo verdad y
digamos lo que nos incumbe aquí es
hablar del radio de este círculo y si
tomamos uno entre el radio de ese
círculo que hemos trazado entonces
obtenemos la curvatura y así es como
obtenemos nuestra curvatura y que
denotamos con capa minúscula verdad y en
realidad cuando calculamos directamente
la curvatura no hablamos de este círculo
verdad pero de hecho es algo muy bueno
que deberíamos tener en mente y para
calcularlo en realidad necesitamos tener
primero el vector tangente a la curva en
cada punto d de esta misma curva verdad
es decir en esencia si nosotros pensamos
en nuestra hélice y por supuesto no soy
tan bueno dibujando hélices como la
computadora verdad pero pues este vector
tangente tendremos un vector tangente
unitario en cada uno de los puntos de
esta curva y eso es lo que está
representado con el vector tdt o la
función vectorial tdt verdad entonces
esto ya sabemos cómo calcularlo en
realidad es el vector derivada de
nuestra función vectorial es verdad y
tendrá que ir dividido entre su propia
norma ya que su magnitud verdad ya que
de esta forma lo hacemos unitario verdad
tiene magnitud 1
y por supuesto nuestro objetivo final
será calcular la derivada de este vector
tangente pero no con respecto al
parámetro t sino con respecto a la
longitud de arco así que primero vamos a
calcular quién es nuestro vector
derivada el vector derivada simplemente
será derivar cada una de las entradas de
este vector así que la derivada del
coche no es menos seno de t la derivada
del seno de t es coseno de t y la
derivada de t en 35 es simplemente un
quinto entonces aquí tenemos este vector
y ahora simplemente calculemos la norma
de este vector verdad que será la raíz
cuadrada de la suma de los cuadrados de
las componentes verdad entonces el
cuadrado de este componente sería seno
cuadrado de t
el cuadrado de éste que es coseno
cuadrado de t más el cuadrado de un
quinto que es 1 sobre 25 muy bien y
quizás notes que suelo utilizar las
funciones seno y cosenos quizás por un
lado es porque suelen dibujar círculos y
esos son bonitos o también porque
simplifican las cosas verdad en realidad
el seno cuadrado más el coseno cuadrado
es uno verdad entonces de aquí lo que
obtendremos es la raíz cuadrada de 1 más
1 sobre 25 muy bien y de hecho podríamos
hacer todavía esto más simple verdad
porque uno es 25 sobre 25 y le sumaremos
1 sobre 25 lo cual nos da 26 sobre 25
verdad entonces aquí tendremos la raíz
cuadrada de 26 sobre 25 y podríamos
incluso distribuir la raíz cuadrada en
esta división verdad tendríamos la raíz
cuadrada de 20
dividido entre la raíz cuadrada de 25
que es 5 y como vimos esto se puede
poner un poco la tos o en otros ejemplos
pero en este en particular es fácil
verdad pues la norma es simplemente una
constante entonces si nosotros
regresamos de este lado vemos que la
norma de esto es sólo una constante y
podemos decir que tdt es simplemente
nuestro vector original que teníamos
dividido entre la norma que como vimos
es raíz de 26 sobre 5 entonces tendremos
que la primer componente es menos seno
de t dividido entre la raíz de 26 sobre
5 que es la norma nuestra segunda
componente voy a hacer esto todavía un
poquito más amplio nuestra segunda
componente será coseno de t dividido
entre este numerito que es raíz de 26
sobre 5 y finalmente tendremos un quinto
un quinto
dividido entre la raíz de 26 sobre 5
bien ahí tenemos quién es nuestro vector
tangente unitario en cada punto de la
curva y mejor vamos a pararle hasta aquí
en este vídeo vamos a continuar con el
cálculo de la curvatura de la hélice en
el próximo vídeo